so we're here on the racetrack at the
home in the British Grand Prix
Silverstone
thanks to our partners Sahara Force
India will be chatting with Esteban Oh
Canadian I'm going on you I'll get to me
good good
you traveled the world are there any
particular countries where their fans
are crazy and the others
Monza really tell you you know the t4z
they are they have something special but
I would say the British Grand Prix here
it's something really special as well
the crowds are really here pushing you
and it's a big boost for for us you know
to see so many fans in the grandstands a
lot of people just see the glitz and the
glamour they see the first quarter see
the crashes what is your race week look
like what do you do you know there is a
saying says the journey is as important
as the destination no that way but you
have to work so hard to to get there and
once you're there you have to keep
working because you know details make
difference in Formula One you obviously
do a lot of preparation what is the
training look like for Formula One
drivers love you think is just sitting
in a car yeah but but it is mag mega
hard it's like getting in the
roller-coaster 13 10 times how it's 6g
you know we are thinking this year which
is as much as a jet fighter but we do it
for two hours and and you know the jet
fighter pilot at five or six years I
have to retire because dangerous for
their body yeah we don't so I couldn't
just jump in the car and driver I'm
afraid no no no I'll go to the gym yeah
totally different we do a lot of Onderon
stuff we have to be strong but as well
on Durin's and we we train special
muscle I connect and if you don't train
it you can you can just collapse
basically it's obviously the sport where
we've got loads of fans who are avid
gamers obviously playing the f1 game is
it how realistic is it and is it kind of
similar to the simulators that you guys
use it's getting closer and closer you
know I mean I I play it so it means that
it's not too bad but no I would say that
the way fun games are big helps along
the tracks and I always enjoy you know
playing one night with online with other
people which are really good something I
know they're playing an f1 driver no I
think a fake ID in case they beat me you
know good yeah so coming from France
football mad country yes you must have a
team yes PSV PSV from from a long time
actually you just a glory hunter the
team with all the money wins all the
titles they're even happy right that's a
bad sentence because you're a bad loser
that's true that's true
before the race a lot of people get like
solo people try and listen to some music
if you could have one album playing or
one musician playing on team radio
during the race who would it be
that would come be touched from Roy
Jones oh can we get a little can we get
a preview no I like it
so the talk of the town in England has
been the super fight between Conor
McGregor and Floyd Mayweather who do you
think's in a win I think my gregor is a
beast you think McGregor is gonna beat
boys yeah I think yes to be fair you
can't argue with MacGregor's record one
out flow doesn't lost
I know I know but my gregor is a proper
beast and I think he's gonna win I've
been Josh turns out with the sport Bible
and this has been Steven Oken
[Music]
[Applause]